[Music]
goodbye 2023 and hello
2024 in this special edition of Koch
news we give you the ultimate rundown
what were the most important events this
past year and what can we expect in the
future we'll get you up to
date the first big highlight was back in
January the brand new bosses of DC James
gun and Peter saffron announced their
plans regarding their future film
Universe the DC you as with Marvel there
will be different phases the first
chapter is called Gods and Monsters
starting in 2025 with James gun's
Superman Legacy much to the
disappointment of many fans Henry caval
will not be returning to the role of the
Man of Steel instead newcomer David
cornat will need to prove himself in the
legendary role moreover the DC elz
worlds are an additional category of
projects that are meant to stand on
their own these include for example the
sequels Joker 2 as as well as the Batman
2o in March it was time for the Academy
Awards Edward Berger's War Drama All
Quiet on the Western Front was one of
the big winners of the prestigious film
Awards and made German film history the
movie won a total of four Oscars
including the title of best
International Film this year's best film
went to the crazy Multiverse Adventure
everything everywhere all at once which
was honored with a total of seven Awards
in the best leading actor category
Brandon Frasier was recognized for his
performance in the
whale in March the first season of The
Last of Us which was highly praised by
fans and critics alike celebrated its
Grand Finale as many as 8.1 million
people watched it this makes the series
starring Bella Ramsey and Pedro Pascal
one of the most successful of the entire
year season 2 is set to follow in 2025
the first mega Blockbuster of the year
was then released in April the eagerly
awaited video game adaptation Super
Mario Brothers made a swapping $1.36
billion at the box office the enormous
success once again demonstrated the
potential of adapting popular video
games into movies later in the year it
was announced that Nintendo's famous
Zelda game series was also to be brought
to the big screen but as a liveaction
version in May Hollywood was hit by one
of the biggest crises of all time the
writer Guild of America called a strike
with significant repercussions for the
whole industry over an impressive
4-month period the writers fought for
better working conditions key issues
included regulations for AI and higher
pay in this era of streaming popular TV
shows were suspended with immediate
effect and the pre-production of planned
Cinema Blockbusters such as Sonic 3 I am
Legend 2 and the Batman 2 also came to a
halt temporarily the next piece of news
was also a bombshell the actors went on
strike as well and joined the fight for
better pay and working conditions in
total over 160,000 members belonged to
to the actor Union sag Afra the
consequences were devastating almost all
major Productions had to be stopped
Hollywood came to a standstill over the
course of the summer months there was
thus a massive wave of postponements and
that included Marvel the entire release
schedule was completely scrapped seven
Productions were pushed back to next
year and some were even postponed
indefinitely this year the MCU was
already struggling with several problems
anyway the anticipated success of major
releases such as Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania and the Marvels failed to
materialize there was also a long period
of uncertainty regarding Kang actor
Jonathan Majors the actor is involved in
an abuse scandal in which he is accused
of domestic violence and assault he was
eventually fired by Marvel at the end of
the year it is unclear what will happen
next because his role as Kang was
originally conceived as the absolute
Central character in the upcoming
Avengers movies fans of James Cameron's
Avatar film series will also have to
wait longer than expected in mid June it
was announced Ed that Avatar 3 avatar 4
and Avatar 5 will be postponed to 2025
2029 and
2031 part five of the Popular Science
Fiction franchise is therefore set to be
released almost 22 years after part
one apart from the strike the 2023 movie
Summer was completely dominated by the
barbin Heimer phenomenon on one side
there was the historical drama opener by
Christopher Nolan 3 hours long but
powerful images partly in black and
white and a huge cast of character
actors around lead actor Killian Murphy
on the other hand was the brightly
colored ironically funny plastic
Adventure Barbie by Greta Gerwig
starring Margo Robbie and Ryan Gosling
two movies that couldn't be any more
different and yet have caused an
incredible sensation at the cinema Greta
gerwig's comedy ended up grossing 1.44
billion at the box office making it the
most successful movie of 2023 but open
Heimer has no reason for dissatisfaction
either with box office takings of $953
million it is the most successful biopic
of all time in contrast things continued
to go downhill in the superhero
Department we have already mentioned the
financial MCU setbacks Ant-Man 3 and the
Marvels but the situation is no better
at DC The Flash proved to be a gigantic
flop Blue Beetle fell short of
expectations and things are currently
looking pretty bad for Aquaman 2 the
final movie of the DC EU the only
promising sign in 2023 was the
performance of Marvel's Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 in May although this
brought the film series to a close for
now the end of the strikes the first
sense of relief for Hollywood came at
the end of September after 148 days the
writers were able to reach an agreement
with the studios and the first strike
was over in November the actors finally
followed suit and also succeeded in
enforcing their demands all in all
Hollywood was thus on break for around 7
months it is estimated that the strike
cost the Southern California economy
more than $6.5 billion it was the first
joint strike in more than 60 years the
effects will be noticeable for a long
time to come numerous Productions are
currently competing over what can be
resumed first over the course of 2024
and 2025 there will also likely be
periods of low activity in terms of new
film and series
releases problems and postponements
aside the release SCH ual for 2024 still
has a lot to offer here are our personal
highlights the first major movie will be
released on Valentine's Day on February
14th Madam web is the next chapter in
Sony's Spider-Man universe the last
movies in the film series morbius and
Venom 2 were rather disappointing for
many viewers however Dune 2 which can
finally celebrate its premiere on March
1st after being postponed due to the
strikes certainly stands a better chance
of success the sequel Kung Fu Panda 4
will be released on March 8 many people
can barely wait for the return of the
hungry fighting Panda Po after all the
previous movie is already 8 years old
then on March 29th we go on another
Ghost Hunt as this is when Ghostbusters
Frozen Empire opens in cinemas anyone in
the mood for Gigantic monster action
will be in for a treat on April 12th in
Godzilla X Kong the new Empire the two
legends will fight the mysterious scar
King we can hardly wait in fact we can
expect a lot of action during this time
the mad next prequel furiosa will be
released on May 24th alongside the
sequel Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes
in June both young and old will be
entertained at the beginning of the
month Anna De armis will try to follow
in John Wick's footsteps with ballerina
accompanied by Kiana Reeves who will
once again slip into a signature role
the sequel to one of the most popular
Pixar movies ever released will be on
June 14th with inside out too those of
you who like it a little more fun will
get their money's worth on July 3rd with
Despicable Me 4 where the popular
minions are once again sure to cause
plenty of chaos on July 26th there will
hopefully be the perfect mix of pureal
humor and bloody action after a lot of
back and forth Deadpool 3 will finally
be released on this day it's going to be
a crazy Multiverse adventure with Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine and numerous guest
appearances by well-known stars and
superheroes there's even more hype in
August we can expect the movie
adaptation of the video game series
Borderlands the latest alien installment
with the working TI Romulus and Sony's
new Spider-Man spin-off Craven the
hunter the classic sequel Beetlejuice 2
in which Wednesday star Jenna Ortega
will also play a key role will be
released on September 6th mid-mon we
will then get to see Transformers 1 on
the big screen a purely animated film
from the famous franchise the exact look
of the project is still a secret Joker 2
fly Ado will be released on October 4th
the highly anticipated sequel with Lady
Gaga and musical performances it remains
to be seen whether the sequel can build
on the success of its acclaimed
predecessor Venom 3 in turn will
hopefully step things up a notch when it
opens on November 8th after all many
fans were rather disappointed by the
second part anyone who was pleased by
Ridley Scott's historical epic Napoleon
should Mark November 22nd in their
calendar because that's when Gladiator 2
will be released featuring Denzel
Washington and many others the movie
year closes on December 13th with the
animated film The Lord of the Rings The
War of the rerum and on December 20th
with the adventurous fun of Sonic the
Hedgehog 3 as you can see there's still
plenty of diversity awaiting us at the
movies in 2024 but those were just a few
highlights from our perspective what are
you particularly looking forward to in
the new year and if you had one wish for
the world of Cinema in 2024 what would
it be we look forward to your comments
we'd like to thank you for all of your
support and wish everyone a Happy New
Year
[Music]